[Music]
my father's name was ervin bloch
my mother was marta and i had a brother
george my grandparents were farmers
which was
quite unusual for a jewish family both
of my
grandparents had farms and my parents
grew up there
i remember my grandmother very well she
was gorgeous her white hair
very lovely and she was
killed when she was 86 years old
by the germans
[Music]
there was very little food the birth was
very
dreadfully hard and that it was
completely closed
[Music]
it was so claustrophobic and there was
absolutely
not enough food for me a lot was
especially
horrible because of the children they
cried and cried and then
they stopped crying one day
they executed i don't know how many
people because
i never had the courage to go and
look they let them hang
on the square for several days
my mother been there because she said
someone
has to pray for them
from time to time the germans came and
they took people away
[Music]
the germans went from
one place to the other and then they let
us go
in the street and there was this always
this
officer a german officer
who said this person goes this way and
this
person goes back and they took all the
old people and the children and took
them away
we went out of the train and they
right there they started dividing women
from men and
i only could see my father's face and he
said
take care of mother and that was all and
i was
you know i didn't see him walking away
it was
just such a crowd you see and um
we worked hand in hand with my mother
and there was a manga and he showed my
mother
to the right side and took and i wanted
to go with her and there was a
soldier and he threw me to the ground
and said you stay here
that's are these people going what's
going to happen to them
and he said don't be hysterical and if
you ask you're going to see them again
very vividly i can i can see
pictures like in a movie you know i can
see
details but i have there is no
connection
and the last
night i
i don't think i spoke to anybody the
whole time i was in action
i just lost all uh capability of
community
communicating with people and i sort of
crawled aside
and i thought my mother and i couldn't
think about
anything except my mother
my mama and i remember
sitting on the ground and hold up my
hand and there was this victim you know
the dandelions
and it came to me and it landed on my
hand and i thought my
mouth she's here i think maybe she just
died that moment
[Music]
you